et c'est Jean-Pierre Molini bonjour
bonjour monsieur vous êtes directeur
adjoint de l'Institut de relation
internationales et stratégiques les
raisons mais sûrement d'entendre notre
envoyé spécial Armel donc en direct de
Lituanie on parle forcément beaucoup
d'armes aujourd'hui parlons peut-être de
la dernière annonce française qu'est-ce
que ça représente pour vous
importante parce que ce missile qui est
un missile de croisière c'est quand même
un missile extrêmement performant qui
permet de tirer à distance de sécurité
sur des cibles renforcés comme des
commandements des notes communication
donc c'est c'est une arme qui peut
désorganiser le système
le système militaire russe sachant que
l'arme sera utilisée sur le territoire
ukrainien que ces missiles ne seront pas
tirés en Russie parce que ça c'est la
ligne que ce sont fixées tous les pays
de l'OTAN missile longue portée scale
pour frapper ce sont les mots d'Emmanuel
Macron en profondeur est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment qu'on passe tout de
même à une à une étape de plus à une
nouvelle étape
on voit bien que les étapes elles sont
franchies petit à petit on a eu l'étape
char de combat au début de l'année
ensuite on a eu la l'étape avion de
combat puisque on est en train de
réfléchir à la livraison de F16 au
à l'Ukraine les Britanniques avaient
déjà annoncé la livraison de missiles
Storm Shadow qui est un peu la version
britannique du missile scalp français
donc des missiles qui vont équiper des
avions de combat je pense que ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a cette
contre-offensive ukrainienne et je pense
que les Occidentaux veulent donner tous
les moyens à zellingski pour que cette
course offensive réussisse et en fait
pour amener la Russie la table de
négociation parce que c'est ça qui
recherche une fille est-ce que ce n'est
pas aussi le signe que cette
contre-offensive et peut-être un peu
plus compliqué difficile que prévu
bien évidemment vous avez des lignes de
défense qui sont extrêmement renforcées
du côté russe vous savez quand même un
combat qui est pour l'essentiel un
combat terrestre avec une
utilisation qui reste relativement
modérée finalement de l'arme aérienne et
puis
l'Ukraine et les Occidentaux sont
limités dans leur capacité de
désorganisation du système militaire
plus puisque encore une fois on ne peut
pas faire enfin c'est une ligne que ce
sont fixées les alliés et qu'ils
imposent aussi à l'Ukraine qui est qu'on
ne peut pas frapper sur le territoire
russe et donc désorganisé le système
russe en sa profondeur
aussitôt prononcé les propos d'Emmanuel
Macron ont fait réagir le Kremlin
porte-parole du Kremlin admetterie
pescov qui a estimé que du point de vue
c'est une décision entachée d'erreur je
le cite lourde de conséquences pour la
partie ukrainienne car naturellement
cela va nous contraindre à prendre des
contre-mesures à quoi faudrait-il
s'attendre
on aura sans doute le
lancement de quelques missiles ou
qu'est-ce que quelques drones sur Kiev
ou sur des grandes villes ukrainiennes
depuis le début du conflit c'est comme
ça que les les Russes réagissent il y a
quand même une volonté de maîtrise de
l'escalade militaire qu'on voit des je
dirais des deux côtés pour le pour le
moment et puis d'autre part encore une
fois l'annonce de d'Emmanuel Macron ne
fait que succéder à l'annonce des
Britanniques qui ont annoncé la
livraison du même type de missile et des
Allemands qui annoncent en tout cas
source gouvernementale des armes
supplémentaires pour un montant tout de
même de 700 millions d'euros il y a une
volonté commune on parlait de cet enjeu
du sommet de l'OTAN de parler d'une même
voix il y a une volonté commune quand
même aujourd'hui de donner les moyens à
Kiev d'en finir une fois pour toutes
au moins de réussir la contre-offensive
ça c'est certain et deuxièmement il y a
quand même le signal qui va être donné
que c'est d'aide va se prolonger dans la
durée et et là le message il est en fait
délivré avait Vladimir Poutine c'est de
dire que ce sera un soutien sans faille
sur la durée et que donc Poutine ne peut
pas gagner cette guerre et encore une
fois le but c'est d'amener les Russes à
la table de négociation alors un soutien
sans faille en tout cas sur le plan
militaire quant à la question de de
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'automneinski a réagi lui aussi il
jugeable sur que l'Ukraine n'est
toujours pas de de calendrier ça ça
n'arrivera pas les Américains l'ont dit
ce matin
oui tout à fait les Américains
effectivement on dit qu'il n'y aurait
pas de calendrier en fait la crainte des
Américains c'est encore une fois
l'escalade militaire et si vous donnez
la certitude que l'Ukraine va appartenir
à l'OTAN à une date donnée
pour Poutine ce sera le signal que de
toute façon c'est c'est comment dire son
objectif initial est et ne peut plus
être atteint et donc le risque en fait
ce serait d'avoir une guerre sans fin
c'est à dire que la seule façon de de se
sortir de cet impasse stratégique de
Poutine serait en fait de vaincre
l'Ukraine il faut quand même laisser la
place à des scénarios qui sont plus
ouverts sur la sur la sortie de sur la
sortie de guerre et c'est ce que
souhaite les les Américains mais
également les Allemands et d'une
certaine manière les les Français
sachant qu'encore une fois il faut bien
voir que pour les Américains le le rival
stratégique c'est pas la Russie c'est la
Chine donc ils ont aussi ça toujours
en arrière-plan qui joue énormément dans
leur décision pour autant le dossier
suédois a peut-être en dire un mot
connait lui une avancée assez inattendue
grâce à la Turquie Ratchet
oui tout à fait mais enfin ça c'est un
grand classique on commence à bien
connaître le dirigeant turc c'est à dire
qu'il bloque en général
les négociations ou la décision jusqu'au
dernier moment il avait fait la même
chose lors du sommet de l'OTAN en 2009
pour la nomination du secrétaire général
de l'OTAN et puis la veille de
l'ouverture du sommet il donne son
accord donc j'ai envie de dire que c'est
c'est presque un peu un business ça
sous-sol Louise avec avec Erdogan sur
sur le sur le fait que la Suède adhère
l'OTAN je pense qu'aussi derrière cette
décision je pense que Erdogan est quand
même conscient qu'il y a cette nécessité
d'unité de tous les pays de l'OTAN et la
Turquie est quand même membre de l'OTAN
donc il ne pouvait pas bloquer
éternellement cette adhésion
merci beaucoup Jean-Pierre Molly